[Música]
[Aplausos]
desde que yo estaba estudiando una
carrera en el área de la salud siempre
me interesó conocer los mecanismos que
conducen a la enfermedad eso me llevó a
estudiar un doctorado investigando los
mecanismos inmunológicos de algunas
enfermedades
el sistema inmune nos protege nos
protege por ejemplo de las infecciones
producidas por virus o por bacterias
también es capaz de ejercer una
vigilancia detectar células extrañas
como células cancerígenas y eliminarlas
pero esto que es protector podría
tornarse en agresor podría hacer que el
sistema inmunológico de repente se
confundiera y empezar a identificar
células o moléculas propias como si
fueran extrañas y las atacara pues si
esto es posible y esto conduce a las
enfermedades autoinmunes estas
enfermedades son muy variadas
seguramente ustedes han oído hablar del
lupus pero incluye también a muchas
otras
por ejemplo la artritis reumatoide la
dermatomiositis les ponen mini tis
anquilosante la escleroderma muchas
el factor común entre ellas es que son
enfermedades inflamatorias crónicas que
cursan con remisiones que los síntomas
se bajan y exacerbaciones que los
síntomas se incrementan
son bastante comunes porque le pueden
afectar hasta una de cada 10 personas de
estos afectados más o menos entre 8 y 10
son mujeres por cada hombre afectado
suelen comenzar temprano en la vida
puede darle incluso a niños pero la edad
más común de inicio es entre los 25 y
los 40 años
yo me encontraba estudiando estas
enfermedades investigando preparándome
pero para lo que no podía estar
preparada era para amanecer un día con
un tobillo muy hinchado para empezar a
sentirme cansada todo el tiempo y
empezar a tener problemas en los ojos y
empezar a visitar médicos hasta que un
médico que además era mi maestro me dijo
lo que yo ya sospechaba que yo tenía una
enfermedad autoinmune
y la primera pregunta cuando a uno le
dan un diagnóstico es porque yo
y un amigo muy querido mi hijo y porque
tú no
el estudiar estas enfermedades te hace
inmune
recibir un diagnóstico así puede ser
muy inquietante cuando estas
enfermedades se inician la cascada de
síntomas puede ser avasallador
hay dolor de articulaciones
articulaciones que uno ni siquiera sabía
o que no se acordaba que tenía comienzan
a doler ustedes saben que cada costilla
está unida al esternón por un cartílago
que puede inflamarse
literalmente duele respirar
como hay muchos órganos sistemas
afectados las manifestaciones pueden ser
muy diversas puede haber manifestaciones
en piel en riñones en los ojos llega un
momento en que lo único que quisiera uno
es ponerse a llorar
pero también dejaste de producir
lágrimas
se puede morir de estas enfermedades no
podemos negar que hay casos graves
severos sin embargo hay buenas noticias
y estas son la reumatología que es el
área de la medicina que trata estas
enfermedades es una de las áreas que han
demostrado un
avance exponencial en los últimos 20 30
años el descubrimiento de medicamentos
biotecnológicos que verdaderamente
logran reducir hacer retroceder todos
estos síntomas ha sido verdaderamente
notable además el diagnóstico se alcanza
cada vez en forma más temprana
debido a los avances en los métodos
diagnósticos entonces es posible salir
de esto sí
no solamente es posible sino que es
posible también tomar el control de las
enfermedades autoinmunes y hay varias
cosas que podemos hacer para
controlarlas
la primera peso y alimentación
la obesidad el sobrepeso son de por sí
ya estados inflamatorios entonces el
comer el consumir alimentos sanos frutas
verduras mejoran los síntomas de estas
enfermedades hay un estudio en el cual a
pacientes con el mismo diagnóstico y el
mismo tratamiento se dividieron en dos
grupos y aún no se le proporciona una
dieta antiinflamatoria rica en alimentos
antioxidantes en verduras frutas frescas
en cereales como la avena especies como
la cúrcuma y algunos otros que cuentan
con respaldo científico que logran
disminuir verdaderamente la inflamación
y no solamente los síntomas sino además
los niveles de las moléculas
inflamatorias que circulan en la sangre
el segundo es la actividad física el
ejercicio estas enfermedades mejoran con
la actividad física es difícil sugerir a
un paciente que tiene dolor que haga
ejercicio
sin embargo empezar por actividad física
leve ejercicios como la natación que no
tienen impacto
sobre las articulaciones van mejorando
los síntomas se puede llegar a
incrementarlo paulatinamente hasta
llegar a hacer ejercicios más fuertes
hay incluso enfermos que suben montañas
que hacen alpinismo que hacen deportes
que no podríamos imaginarnos ganan
carreras de natación y todos los
deportes que se puedan imaginar el
tercero es tener una mentalidad positiva
si el estrés la depresión desencadenan
estas enfermedades
entonces el tener una mente positiva
ayuda a hacerla retroceder la tristeza
es una muy mala amiga si la abrimos un
poquito la rendija se mete se cuela y
luego no hay manera de sacarlas entonces
no la dejes entrar
simplemente aléjate de aquellas
situaciones que te hagan sentir triste
ansioso deprimido o estresado
sin embargo el estrés positivo aquel que
nos llena de adrián y la que nos hace
levantarnos ese es bueno y ese es el
cuarto punto el cuarto punto es insistir
levantarse cada vez
nunca hacerse para atrás cuando vamos
nadando contra la corriente puede
parecer tentador descansar un momento
sin embargo si descansamos la corriente
nos puede arrastrar y podemos perder el
camino que habíamos logrado avanzar
entonces hay que insistir levántate
actívate saca ese cuerpo dolorido de la
cama si es posible empieza poco a poco
no retroceda insiste ser muy terco
acuérdate que si tienes períodos malos
estos son temporales y que siempre
puedes mejorar y puedes tomar el control
de tu enfermedad y puedes llegar no
solamente a tener una vida plena sino
muy feliz y puedes llegar a hacer cosas
que no te habías imaginado que podías
hacer
puedes descubrir que si ya has pasado
por esto hay muy pocas cosas que te
puedan dar miedo y que te puedan echar
para atrás entonces insiste siempre
sigue adelante
el símbolo de lupus son las mariposas
las mariposas son insectos que pueden
parecer muy frágiles sin embargo hay
mariposas tan fuertes como la mariposa
monarca que es capaz de emigrar miles de
kilómetros desde méxico hasta canadá
un día puedes ver que efectivamente que
cojeaba te costaba trabajo caminar pero
poco a poco puedes ir avanzando llegas a
correr y un día vas a ver que es incluso
posible llegar a bailar con tacones
muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]